[Music]
recently iran replaced former president
mahmoud ahmadinejad who was a holocaust
denier
with a new president who is frequently
described as a moderate so people have
been hoping maybe this guy will you know
will be better he'll be more tolerant
well apparently that's true last night
was the start as i said of the jewish
holiday of rosh hashanah check out this
actual tweet from iran's new president
hassan
rouhani this is real as the sun is about
to set here in tehran i wish all jews
especially iranian jews a blessed rosh
hashanah that's that's
that's progress
think that's very hopeful that's
terrific
i thought that was a great sign well
guess what since then in the last couple
of hours president rouhani's been
sending out even more friendly tweets to
the jewish people i like this guy
there's this one right here
woody allen just kills it with blue
jasmine
there's this next one i've died and gone
to paradise keep up the great job
lenders bagels
look at this larry king you ain't got no
jufro but you is my jew bro
miss you
look at this one the jews control the
media and they're doing a great job
hashtag orange is the new black
look at this one wtf some schmendrick
drank all my menishevitz
look at this one if any one of these
tweets bombed it was written by conan's
one non-jew writer
check this one out breyer kagan bader
ginsburg man hebrews be crushing it on
the scotus
and the last one
gotta say i'm thinking about giving this
circumcision thing a whirl hashtag
calamari
this is very hopeful